publisher koei tecmo have released a
brand new trailer for their upcoming
attack on Titan game which confirms the
action games release date the trailer
confirms it attack on Titan which is the
game's working title will come to ps4
ps3 and Vita in February of next year
currently that release date is only for
Japan and the publisher are yet to
reveal when the game will arrive in the
West the game did get an English teaser
recently though so we can assume it's on
the way the game is based on the first
season of the anime of the same name the
new trailer shows off new cutscenes with
characters from the show including Eren
Mikasa Levi Sasha and Pyxis it also
displays a more extensive look at how
the gameplay is going to work and how
the 3d maneuver gear plays out in combat
the game Steve Alpha Omega force is
known for a number of action games
including the dynasty warriors series
and the recently released Hyrule
warriors for all the latest on the
attack on Titan game and everything else
that matters in gaming be sure to stay
tuned to gamespot